então eu vou começar falando né de um
audi o anúncio de uma agonia não é que
houve já
a gente tem apoio no início da década de
90 é em que o quando um cidadão chamado
paulo cuja mãe escreveu um livro
publicado no brasil
chamava indústria cultural dois pontos
agonia de um conceito então a minha o
ponto de partida é da minha fala que
hoje é que teria acontecido a indústria
cultural estaria em agonia até hoje ela
teria já morrido né
então naturalmente pelo título da minha
palestra fica claro que não né que ela
não morreu mas que ela se transformou
nós temos 2.0 para usar um pouco a
linguagem da tecnologia quando o
contemplado não é com uma nova versão
não é bom então comece falando um pouco
da origem da indústria cultural
é interessante que desde meados do final
do século 19
existe uma indústria artesanal do
entretenimento né que se transformou
radicalmente a partir da apropriação de
invenções exatamente daquele período né
como o gramofone o cinema
o rádio é certo e isso deu origem né há
o que veio a ser criticamente colocado
na década de 1940 por adorno e
horkheimer último sob a rubrica de
indústria cultural
isso aconteceu primeiramente no na
europa nos países mais industrializados
na europa principalmente frança grã
bretanha e a partir de inícios do século
20 houve uma migração nada do
desenvolvimento principal da indústria
cultural para os estados unidos da
américa não é e por volta de 1915
houve uma migração ainda interno estados
unidos da costa leste para a costa oeste
norte-americana né
bom então a crítica do adorno e
horkheimer eu resumo ela em cinco
operadores né
a manipulação retroativo é o primeiro o
segundo é a usurpação do esquematismo
terceiro domesticação do estilo quarto
disputa em sinalização do trágico e 5 é
o fetichismo da mercadoria cultural
começando então com a manipulação
retroativa a indústria cultural ela é
muito poderosa no sentido de do seu
público achar que está escolhendo coisas
quando na verdade está sendo no mínimo
induzido a fazer aquelas escolhas né
e é isso é essa manipulação porque é
retroativa porque tudo que é oferecido
pela indústria cultural é baseado
exatamente em demandas latentes no seu
público né
então existe uma série de mecanismos que
eu vou dizer depois que hoje são muito
mais aperfeiçoados nesse sentido né
o segundo momento que é usurpação do
esquematismo esse é conceitualmente mais
complexo porque remete ao conceito de
esquematismo que é um conceito que vem
de emmanuel kant o filósofo alemão é do
século 18 é que ele dizia o seguinte que
nós temos uma sensibilidade um sensor
you né
e nós temos no nosso entendimento a
nossa razão e eles são duas faculdades
digamos né
é da nossa mente pra falar de um modo
geral do nosso ânimo completamente
separadas e que é necessário um
mecanismo que é também que faz parte
também do nosso ânimo que faz a ligação
entre o que nós percebemos que o modo
como nós processamos as informações do
nosso censório esse mecanismo é
exatamente o esquematismo né
e ele quanto ao como kant concebeu é
alguma coisa que como kant diz vêm das
profundezas da alma é um segredo oculto
nas profundezas da alma de um
determinado sujeito não é
a indústria cultural a ideia é que ela
usurpe do sujeito
essa faculdade de esquematismo porque
ela oferece produtos audiovisuais por
exemplo que já vem com a sua própria
interpretação digamos assim colada neles
próprios né
a domesticação do estilo é o estilo é um
conceito que na estética existe pra
falar a verdade desde a antiguidade mas
é um conceito que ganhou relevo na
estética a partir do século 18 e 19
e ele sempre queria dizer o seguinte que
os grandes artistas grandes criadores da
chamada grande arte burguesa e tetra
eles estavam subordinados a determinadas
formas para suas criações mas eles
tinham liberdade para dentro daquilo é
continuarem é criando e propondo coisas
novas etc e que a indústria cultural ela
faz com o estilo exatamente o contrário
ela impede os padrões as formas são tão
violentamente né imóveis estáticas que
não há como que esse momento de criação
do artista valer né
o trágico tradicionalmente desde a
tragédia grega era um momento de
confronto de um indivíduo com potências
universais não é é isso quer dizer
sempre dava uma esperança de que os
indivíduos poderiam se ver né com essas
potências que os transcendiam muito na
sua força etc
mas o na indústria cultural
o adolfo caminha dizem que o trágico
reduzido a uma fórmula que eles mesmo no
texto original alemão eles usam o inglês
que é assim
jett nem à tropa e na hora guiné então
assim o trágico é reduzido a uma um
embrulho em que o protagonista entra e o
final do filme o da novela do que for é
realmente sair daquilo ea coisa se reduz
a isso não é bom
o último é o fetichismo da mercadoria
cultural que é um entrecruzamento
digamos de duas tendências importantes
né novamente o canto mas agora não mais
a sua epistemologia mas a sua estética
ele dizia que o objeto estético ele é
uma finalidade sem fim porque ele sugere
a existência de um propósito pra aquele
objeto mas ele não explicita qual seria
essa finalidade
por outro lado a indústria cultural ela
ela não vende apenas produtos mas ela
vem de status eo faz parte dos 12 do
status que a indústria cultural vende
exatamente é os seus produtos é parecer
em que não tenham não tão é voltado para
uma finalidade quando na verdade estão
que a finalidade dos ditames do mercado
então esse é o fetichismo da indústria
cultural bom
a indústria cultural de hoje que foi
chamada já de indústria cultural global
e outras denominações eu chamo de
indústria cultural 2.0
ela é ela está submetida a duas grandes
questões a primeira foi uma mudança
geopolítica muito importante que ocorre
a partir do início dos anos 90 que é o
fim da guerra fria o início da
globalização não é é é que fez com que a
indústria cultural ela fosse realmente
globalizada
a idéia do makro de uma global village
desde os anos 60 ela realmente é só pode
ser realizada pela primeira vez a partir
do início da década de 90
então esse é um fenômeno outro fenômeno
é a questão da matriz tecnológica é
então o o o registro não é a geração ea
transmissão de mensagens principalmente
audiovisuais é pela digitalização né
então eu gostaria de passar rapidamente
em revista é esse cinco operadores que
eu uso para estudar a indústria cultural
do ponto de vista da indústria cultural
2.0
a manipulação retroativa como eu sugeri
ela dependia muito de realização de
pesquisas de opinião para saber quais
eram as necessidades latentes do público
e oferecer produtos que atender essa
demanda dando uma formulação que fosse
mais interessante não próprio público
mais pros por centros de poder econômico
político etc
a flexibilidade dos meios digitais hoje
ela é possibilita exatamente uma
sofisticação muito maior nessa nessa
pesquisa sobre as demandas latentes né a
usurpação de esquematismo ela dependeu
muito
se consolidar do realismo dos meios
tecnológicos não é como os meios
digitais são muito mais realistas então
houve também um aumento na possibilidade
de usurpação dos camatte zta pela
indústria cultural 2.0 né
houve a possibilidade de uma difusão
muito maior digamos um acesso muito
maior pelos criadores aos meios de
criação de difusão e só é evidente a
gente tem que conceder isso com toda
tranquilidade né
talvez em relação a isso tenha criado
assim talvez pequenas indústrias
culturais paralelas à indústria cultural
nem stream
mas essa indústria cultural uma extrema
ela aumentou ainda digamos a sua rigidez
nos padrões não é a disponibilização do
trágico 2.0 é tem a ver com um aumento
nas tendências de espetacularização é
que era um recurso usado já para a
disputa em sinalização do trágico na
indústria cultural convencional né e
principalmente em relação a acatar se
acatar sem esse mecanismo de purificação
das emoções que eles tottenham e estudou
na sua poética né e que o adorno ro km é
chegar à conclusão que é ouro e quer
algo típico dessa de potencialização do
trágico né então hoje a indústria
cultural 2.0 ela continua e também
aperfeiçoou exatamente esses mecanismos
de catárticos nas massas e tal e
principalmente falando da indústria
cultural 2.0 ligada à grande indústria
realmente né
é exatamente aquela ideia do gat no
tropa 1 e na alta guiné pode agora
ganhar contornos né e antes impensadas
tendo em vista os efeitos mais realistas
né e do que nunca da dos que os meios
digitais proporcionam né
a indústria cultural convencional ela
dependia muito da escala dos produtos
pensar discos de vinil era muito caro e
só vale a pena
mas há milhares de discos etc hoje quer
dizer um criador pode gravar o seu álbum
em casa né no home studio com
relativamente poucos recursos e com a
qualidade impensável até muito melhor
pra época certa né
então diante desses novos recursos da
indústria cultural
é o que acontece é que ela ela se
diversifica né
é a indústria cultural 2.0 no que tange
a aaa o fetichismo surgem é essa ocorre
uma segmentação muito maior dos meios da
indústria né
então por exemplo a questão dos dos
recursos tecnológicos
sim a ideia da capilarização não é dos
recursos
os criadores eles não só os criadores o
público tem capacidade de resposta não é
isso tem a ver com o fetichismo ea
segmentação que eu estava falando e
agora pra encerrar a segmentação ela é
uma customização né que ocorre na
verdade né então produtos voltados cada
vez mais o público em vez de lucrar na
economia de escala lucrar na
possibilidade de maior valor agregado
aos produtos né terminou nem a minha é a
exposição perguntando não é porque eu
estudo esse assunto da indústria
cultural global 2.0 há mais de dez anos
15 anos talvez e eu próprio sempre tem
que rever meus pontos de vista
exatamente pelos desenvolvimento
tecnológico que tornam as vezes quase
obsoletos afirmações que eu fiz um ano
dois três anos atrás né então eu deixo a
pergunta no ar não é
é como seria então o próximo
desenvolvimento da indústria cultural
ok é isso muito obrigado
[Aplausos]